el alcalde de esas nits es un hombre que
está molesto su blanco el presidente
norteamericano donald trump por estos
días en sus needs se vive un ambiente de
guerra fría todo esto debido a un
gasoducto del norte stream-2 que debe
unir a rusia y alemania- y que no le
gusta al presidente de estadounidense
donald trump la pequeña ciudad ubicada
en la isla de rügen al noroeste de
alemania ha sido amenazada con sanciones
estadounidenses y los adultos mayores
del puerto mercantil aún no pueden
creerlo francamente es ridículo y todo
ello porque estás nits construye un
gasoducto es tan arrogante estamos en
alemania no no le corresponde a una
potencia extranjera decirnos lo que
debemos hacer y la cuestionada obra debe
aprovisionar europa con gas ruso
esquivando los países bálticos ucrania y
polonia para evitar pagar aranceles de
tránsito sólo faltan 150 kilómetros por
construir
pero para washington que también
quisiera venderle su gas a europa este
gasoducto representa una amenaza para la
seguridad energética del continente la
primera advertencia tuvo lugar en agosto
con una carta enviada por senadores
estadounidenses al alcalde de la ciudad
el principal accionista del puerto
industrial ha sido amenazado de
sanciones jurídicas y económicas por
varios miles de millones de dólares
al final de dicha carta está escrito
destroy
esto significa que dichas sanciones
pretenden destruir nuestra empresa
comunal debe ser destruida
se le apunta a la dirección así como a
los 70 asalariados de la compañía
portuaria no se les aconseja ir a eeuu
tomamos muy en serio esta amenaza es
evidente que eeuu está determinado a
asustarnos ya imponer sus intereses a la
fuerza si de hecho no es el primer
ensayo de eeuu tras la promulgación de
una ley en washington que impone
sanciones contra empresas asociadas a la
construcción del gasoducto las obras
fueron suspendidas en diciembre y por
ahora nada deja entrever que la obra se
ha reiniciado porque una nueva oleada de
sanciones europeas esta vez podría
golpear el gasoducto tras el posible
envenenamiento del opositor del kremlin
alexéi navalni en berlín los llamados a
que se detenga el proyecto se
multiplican y el gobierno no lo excluye
por completo el proyecto nord stream 2
tampoco generó unanimidad aquí en
especial en las filas conservadoras y
sigue siendo difícil defenderlo nosotros
los alemanes nunca tuvimos la
posibilidad de defender de manera
racional y adecuada a este proyecto nord
stream 2 porque fue lanzado hace 15 años
por un antiguo canciller gerhard
schröder y este mismo canciller gana hoy
en día mucho dinero trabaja
para un proveedor de energía ruso
entonces esto genera desde siempre la
desconfianza de nuestros aliados y es
desafortunado de cualquier forma para
los especialistas del expediente no
existe duda alguna en cuanto a que el
asunto naval y tiene el potencial para
torpedear definitivamente el gasoducto
nord stream 2 según la economista
claudia kemfert la sanción sería en
efecto más dolorosa para moscú que para
alemania y los otros países europeos
implicados en el proyecto el gasoducto
nord stream 2 sería una muy buena
palanca porque golpearía de manera
sensible rusia las empresas europeas que
trabajan en este proyecto serían
impactadas pero los daños más
significativos estarían del lado ruso
que espera vender gas durante los
próximos decenios gracias a este
gasoducto los daños para rusia serían
muy importantes sería sensato pensar en
una suspensión del proyecto en este
conflicto las nits sería por lo tanto
una víctima colateral entre otras
mientras tanto más de mil tubos de gas
destinados a la construcción de los
últimos kilómetros de gasoducto vegetan
en el puerto de la ciudad una
astro fe para este responsable local de
la cdu es preocupante porque no sabemos
lo que ocurrirá con nuestros tubos y el
proyecto es difícil sobre todo porque no
podemos hacer nada distinto a esperado
en controles kaim y sus colegas
invitaron a los senadores
estadounidenses que amenazan su ciudad a
visitarlos sin mucha esperanza
actualmente cuentan sobre todo con la
cancillera angela merkel para arreglar
este conflicto y preservar sus empleos
para la región esta esfera es muy
difícil porque no se sabe de dónde
llevará y cómo podremos desarrollarnos
económicamente si el proyecto no
continúa estos tubos permanecerán en el
puerto lo cual impedirá que otras
empresas hagan negocios los empleos
están en general para la región sería un
callejón sin salida atrapada en un
conflicto geopolítico que la supera la
pequeña ciudad de esas nits está en vilo
para el centenar de empresas europeas
que hacen parte de este proyecto las
pérdidas podrían ser de varios miles de
millones de euros